es ist ein erlebnis das man nicht mal
seinem schlimmsten feind wünscht diana
pacheco aus berlin ist es passiert
bei ihr wurde eingebrochen mehrfach wir
sehen hier die videoaufnahmen den
dreisten dieb bei seiner tat ertappen
und letztendlich überführen
der dieb ist nicht irgendwer nein er ist
ihr direkter nachbar der den ball cool
einsteigt dann sich ein schlüssel
nachmachen lässt und in frecher
regelmäßigkeit bei jana hansen einsteigt
doch sie hatte den mut wie wir hier in
diesem video sehen ihn zu stellen
hier sehen wir in dem video wie sie tür
an tür neben dem täter lebte der balkon
nur geteilt durch ein gitter im november
2020 bemerkte anna dass schlüssel fehlen
und gingen auf einbrecher jagd in ihrer
eigenen wohnung sie bestellte zwei
kameras und konnte so stefan zeeh bei
seiner nächsten tat filmen
die polizei schnappte ihn das ungute
gefühl jedoch blieb davon berichtet jana
uns jetzt live bei uns im studio
schön dass du da bist ja na hallo hallo
und herzlich willkommen erstmal
herzlichen glückwunsch zu deinem mut ob
man da überhaupt zu gratulieren kann
aber ich bin es wirklich sehr mutig dass
du ihn selber gestellt hast was war das
für ein gefühl also die kamera aufnahmen
gesehen hast und bemerkt hast es ist ein
direkter nachbar gewesen also das erste
was ich gedacht habe es das tatsächlich
sich gelohnt hat die glauben wir dass zu
kaufen und die daran zu stellen
leider vielleicht ein bisschen zu spät
aber man lernt ja schon erfahrung
ich hatte tatsächlich mich gefreut dass
ich dann den gefangenen habe es ging ja
darum das war mein ziel dass ich dann
fangen könnte und dann ist es passiert
und reizte ihn überführt hatte
denn er wohnt ja nicht mehr neben dir
nämlich man trotzdem hat sie es
wahrscheinlich direkt dem mieterbund und
der polizei gemeldet was ist mit einem
nachbar passiert ich meine die 30 kam in
der wohnung der nachbarin mehrfach
einzubrechen ist ja schon wirklich los
es ist tatsächlich nicht unruhig gewesen
die letzte woche legt dann noch in der
wohnung verbrachten verbracht habe bevor
ich in den urlaub gefahren bin
in werde nicht in dem urlauber wurde der
täter gefangen und da hab ich mich
gefreut
mein freund hat die app hatte für die
kamera
tomasso den alarm und der kamera hatte
er mich in der nacht an
es war in der nacht hier vier uhr
morgens da hat ja bescheid gegeben im
büro war es nach mitternacht und da hab
ich mich gefreut ich habe gleich meine
hausverwalter angerufen und er meinte
die polizei wer schon bei ihm gewesen
hat sich die schlüssel abgehalten hat
den täter gleich in der wohnung dann
noch gefasst waren sie überrascht als
sie gesehen haben dass er das war sie
haben daher wahrscheinlich sofort
erkannt oder hatten sie schon so ein
bisschen den verdacht dass könnte der
sein und ich brauch eingenommen beweisen
nein ich dachte es wäre jemand anders
gibt es noch ein anderer komischer
nachbar ja ich hatte tatsächlich 228
personen im haus ich dachte nicht ich
habe nichts weiter gedacht das ja es
wäre sonst hätte ich niemals vielleicht
dann die tür von meinem balkon offen
gelassen
und ich habe die gewohnheit sie die tür
offen zu lassen weil ich dann besser
atmen kann
und als ich dann erfahren habe von
meinen hausverwalter denn er hatte es in
dem video kann und die polizei hatte ihm
das auch gesagt dann habe ich mich echt
erschreckt dass ich dann die ganze zeit
über mit den offenen tür von dem balkon
geschlafen hatte ohne es zu wissen dass
mein täter also mein mann liebt der dieb
dann gleich neben mir schlafen
er hätte auch in der nacht dann zu mir
herüber kommen können
gegen etwas machen können weiß ich nicht
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren